سلطه العمليه العسكريه التركيه الضوء من
جديد على الوضع المعقد شمال سوريا كانت
عمليه جويه ويبدو انها ستتحول قريبا
لعمليه رابعه منذ العام 2016 الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اعلنها صراحه
اليوم بعدما كانت تلميحات بالامس قائلا ان
بلاده ستشن قريبا عمليه بريه في سوريا ضد
المقاتلين الاكراد اردوغان صرح في خطاب
المسلسل بان طائرات ومدافع ومسيرات بلاده
حلقت فوق من اسمائهم بالارهابيين لبضعه
ايام مضيفا سنقتلعهم جميعا قريبا
بالدبابات بالمدفعيه والجنود
[موسيقى]
حلقنا فوق الارهابيين لبضعه ايام
بطائراتنا ومدافعنا ومسيراتنا سنقتلعهم
جميعا قريبا بالدبابات والمدفعيه والجنود
اعلم هذا
تصريحات الرئيس التركي اضاف عليها وزير
الداخليه
بالقول ان تركيا ان لم تسمح باقامه ما
وصفها بدوله الارهابيه عند حدودها سويل
قال انه يجب على تركيا
ومواطنها وهذا حق المشروع لكل دوله هذا ما
تستمر القوته التركيه بعمله اذن على ما
يبدو بانتظار العمليه البريه المرصد
السوري افادى اليوم بمقتل عنصرين من قوات
سوريا ديمقراطيه قصد
مع اصابته الثلاثه بقصف لمسيره تركيا على
قاعده عسكريه في الحسكه
[موسيقى]
التحركات التركيه والتصعيد والتهديد
بالعمليه البريه الرابعه
لكنه في الوقت نفسه دعى الاطراف كافه الى
تجنب الخطوات التي قد تؤدي الى تدهور
الوضع الامني وحذر انقراما ان اي مبادره
يمكن ان تؤدي الى زعزعه خطيره للوضع العام
في سوريا
نفهم مخاوف تركيا المرتبطه بامنها لكن في
الوقت عينه ندعو جميع الاطراف الى
الامتناع عن اي مبادره يمكن ان تؤدي الى
زعزعه خطيره للوضع العام
اللاعب الرئيس الاخر شمال سوريا الولايات
المتحده وا عبر متحدث باسم وزاره خارجيتها
عبر عن معارضه واشنطن لاي تحرك عسكري
يزعزع استقرار الوضع في سوريا واضاف بانه
واشنطن ابلغت انقره بقلقها البالغ من
تاثير التصعيد على هدف محاربه تنظيم داعش
فيما تسعى قصد الى وقت التصعيد التركيه
ضدها عبر التواصل مع واشنطن بحسب قائدها
العام مظلوم عبدي مع انه يرى ان الموقف
الامريكي موقف النظام السوري من مقتل
عناصر بالغارات التركيه ضعيف للغايه
[تصفيق]